- Hi I'm Sal Khan, founder
of the Khan Academy
and I just wanted to let you
know how excited all of us are
for what we have in store
this coming back to school.
First and foremost, this
is going to be a big effort
in terms of working with
teachers and classrooms.
This coming back to school,
teachers are going to be able
to better assign practice on Khan Academy
and get reports on
where their students are
to give optimal personalized practice.
This practice is going to
be aligned with standards
across subjects and grades.
We're also adding a lot more content
and to be clear, Khan Academy
is much much much more
than just videos, we have
standards-aligned practice
across subjects and grades,
keep a look out for well beyond
math, biology, chemistry,
physics, and especially
this coming year, we're
adding a lot in history.
We're creating many tools
for independent learners
and folks who are trying
to prepare for college
and important standardized
exams like the SAT.
We're really trying to reach the world.
Our mission is a free
world class education
for anyone anywhere, so we're
going to continue our efforts
in Spanish, in Portuguese, in Hindi,
and launch in other
significant geographies.
So there's a lot of work ahead of us,
but we're very very very
excited and I just wanna thank
all of y'all for being part
of the Khan Academy community.
And many of you have directly
supported these efforts
and I hope you too feel
proud of all of the reach
and impact that we are
able to collectively have.